today i had a couple of meetings near
manchester and i had a bit of spare time
so i visited three river crossings all a
bit strange and all with something in
common although i guess technically
these are canal crossings but some of
the canal is a diverted river so look
i went with river crossings it sounds
better my first stop was the humes ferry
and i took my gopro and my drone with me
like all the three crossings the humes
ferry goes over the manchester ship
canal that canal runs for nearly 60
kilometers starting in the mersey
estuary in the irish senior liverpool
and running through to manchester it's
more than a century old the canal is a
massive engineering achievement but it's
not like the builders just smashed
through anything that was in their way
it was the industrial revolution but
still the act of parliament that gave
permission for the canal back in 1885
included a lot of requirements to make
sure all the landowners along the route
were well if not happy at least
satisfied embankments or channels had to
be maintained or built access had to be
provided fees had to be paid 300 pages
of technical legal details some of which
still apply to this day also you'd think
that by now every bit of uk law would be
online and freely available but no i
found most of this in archived freedom
of information requests on obscure
things from years ago
anyway one of those legal requirements
from 1885 is a ferry by night and by day
whenever required to replace a low
bridge that they had to knock down
if i'm being honest there's not really
much need to have a ferry like that in
the 21st century you wouldn't start a
new ferry service there today yes it was
useful in the past it's an hour's walk
to get to the other side but unless you
happen to live really close to one side
and work really close to the other it's
not actually much use for almost every
practical purpose it's quicker to drive
there are regular passengers so the
ferry driver said in an interview a
couple years ago but
not that many it's mostly walkers and
cyclists out for the fun of it but my
travel on it was logged one more on the
count of people who actually use this
ferry and i'll get back to why that
happened later a few kilometers west was
my second stop the fell wall ferry
actually it might be tell wall i didn't
meet anyone to ask and there's no
official website or information about it
but it's much the same arrangement
although this time with a small charge
11 pence oh and that boat doesn't have
an engine it's just powered by a
hardworking man rowing you across just
as there's been for more than 120 years
not the same man obviously i'm not the
same boat either and when i turned up
there was a small sign in the window of
the pheromones cottage saying that
service was suspended due to low water
levels in the canal
i'll be honest those water levels look
fine to me but i'm not the expert
low water levels aside the ferry
continues because the law says that the
company shall work the said ferry
whenever required
the company by the way is called the
peel group these days after a lot of
buying and selling and corporate
renaming and mergers
they're an enormous property investment
firm who owned the entire manchester
ship canal along with what seems like
every major bit of land and private
infrastructure around manchester i've
reached out to them with interview
requests before for other stuff and
they've always turned me down so this
video
i have to rely on secondary sources
newspaper articles and quotes i don't
like doing that but from the look of
some of those articles it's not just me
that they've turned down requests from
which is fair they're absolutely within
the rights to do that
and if i'm honest the second reason that
i'm sort of improvising here and relying
on those quotes and articles i only
found out i was traveling to manchester
yesterday morning so i had to spend the
entire rest of the day just researching
at home trying to get the law right so
the fell wall ferry or tel wall about
600 crossings a year they say some days
there's barely anyone other days a whole
walking club might turn up and want to
go across at 11 pence each
the third crossing in between those two
ferries is the warberton toll bridge
which is a deeply frustrating bridge for
a lot of people because the toll to
cross in a car is 12 pence or 25 pence
if you want a day pass and there is
often a queue cash only no change given
and it seems almost farcical to have a
toll collector and a barrier and
sometimes very long hues for 12 pence a
time
except when i got there and i drove up
no charges but wanting to get the shot i
turned around and went back over and
they were charging that way but no day
passes either just a man with a coin
bucket and no change
uh no daily tickets that's 20p then
thank you
one of the nice things about improvising
this video is that i've seen things as
they actually were not as the pr teams
would want them to be anyway this toll
it made sense when the bridge was built
for every carriage drawn or propelled by
steam or any means other than animal
power two shillings and sixpence back
then that was worth collecting adjusted
for inflation that'll be about 15 pounds
but the law did not mention inflation
the company could choose to wave the
tolls at any time they did that during
the covered lockdown last year and i
guess they're doing that one way right
now but if you stop collecting tolls for
the long term
it's a lot more difficult to bring them
back and they'd still be required to
maintain the bridge if there's one car
in each direction every 30 seconds on
average and looking at that yeah there
is
well that's still about a quarter
million pounds of revenue every year
so you'll see people talk about the
story of old quirky british laws that
mean you still have these fairies and
you still have that toll bridge oh they
must be maintained by law and is it
weird what happens in rural britain but
i don't think the law
is the reason that those crossings are
still there
because there are two ways that you
could interpret whenever required in
those old legal documents whenever
required could mean
whenever anyone asks for it if someone
turns up any hour of any day the ferry
must be there waiting for them it's a
valid interpretation but that's not how
those words have been read through
history and it's not how they're being
read now the humes ferry only runs for a
few hours three or four days a week and
never in winter and it stopped running
for a year back in 2010 it took a
campaign and local effort to get it
reinstated as for the fell wall ferry it
runs most days but only for a few hours
and apparently not when the water's low
remember i said my crossing was logged
and counted
well you can also interpret whenever
required to mean if there is reasonable
demand there's no official website for
the humes ferry and it says use it or
lose it those old laws mention other
fairies they've all gone i don't know if
they were removed through legal process
or just forgotten about because
ultimately no one's complaining and if
someone did complain well who in
government is going to take action about
a ferry that almost no one uses
i think these ferries and the 12 pence
toll have stuck around because it would
be more effort for the giant corporation
to try and stop them it's a minor thing
for a multi-billion pound company to pay
for a couple of ferry boats compared to
having to deal with angry locals and bad
press and i think the toll on that
bridge has stayed at 12 pence for so
long because increasing it would have
required a change in the law and trying
to get that through is way more
time-consuming and expensive than just
keeping things as they are in our own
lives we make do with a lot of small
bothersome things and irritations
because it's less work than trying to
fix them
different scale same principle although
i'm not saying that the ferries are a
bothersome thing i think they're
brilliant i think we should have more
quirky useful things funded by
multi-billion dollar corporations i'm
just saying that the company has bigger
things to deal with if they wanted to
they could probably get away without the
ferries and i to guess
i reckon it's not worth the hassle of
not running them
but one thing is changing soon that
bridge needs expensive refurbishment
maybe even replacement soon which means
that the company hasn't noticed it and
suddenly changing the law
might be worth their time there was a
consultation process for the locals last
month the company would like to raise
the toll up to a whole
one pound and replace the ticket booths
with automatic systems so
if you do want the novelty of the 12
pence toll
now's the time to go because the law
will probably change quite soon as for
the ferries i do hope that the locals
will make sure that removing them never
becomes the easy option
you